so we've been through these 76 names
because of that tie that make up the
75th anniversary team and then you just
you know what you talk about wow i
wonder
i know how how this guy didn't make it
or should this guy have possibly false
objective yeah it is i have a question
just which of those names man
well okay so
three guys influenced my game i studied
adrian dadley john drew and clark
kellogg i stuttered those guys really so
i got love for adrian donnelly and
obviously my man john drew and clark
kellogg but i will say this vince carter
and i'm not taking anybody off the list
ms carter should be on the list
yeah i mean
all of these guys they have a case
without question all of those guys to me
have a case
i'm also
if i'm missing it the yao ming was not
even on the
uh no he's not on it but he wasn't even
on the mic list he should be at least on
the miss list like uh on people that
missed yeah not not not before decay i'm
not saying that he should i mean but he
should be a name that's going to be
associated what i'm just saying as far
as like you look at the list like the
kembe mutombo vince carter bernard king
brett hill for me bernard king was you
know yeah i don't even want to miss i'll
never miss bernard but all of those guys
could make a case for sure i'm gonna go
with grant hill
you know adrian dadley oh my god i know
a lot of people say if he wouldn't got
hurt but when he was playing he was
definitely an impact especially in
detroit and even in phoenix so grant
hill should have been on that on that
list
when i saw
i had a place in my heart for dikembe
mutumbo when i when i voted on this uh
because i think he represents not only
what he did on the floor
four-time defensive player of the year
hall of famer
number two in blocks all time but also
how he used the platform of the nba
yes after his playing days to further to
further
um he just blocked my shot
his reputation for all he's done for the
hospitals
he's a guy
who represents the best of the nba in
terms of
product on the floor
and an eye for
helping other folks i mean amazing he's
just been such a great former ambassador
for the game a great man and a great
player could i could i represent some
guys who probably i'm like i was a big
fan before i ever even touched the
basketball yeah but guys like alex
english
adrian dadley those guys don't get
enough credit they led the league in
scoring they were tough to guard they
were they would live in this era
probably average 25 to 30 points a game
you know there's a group of guys
that
yeah that need a lot of there's a group
put a period on what we've seen here
tonight on the 75. i don't know if i can
do that um
but i think we we do understand that any
time you create a list which you know
it's tough it's going to be someone left
off and you know of course i love vince
carter i thought of course i mean i love
chris bosh i love dwight howard like i
love these young players these younger
players that have great careers you know
so
it's always going to be someone left off
but overall like i should be on that
list dennis johnson
there's a lot of guys that should be on
the list possibly yeah man so look
about 20 years you're gonna be on the
list yeah that's right the 5000 best nba